si c'est depuis cinq heures du matin
alors qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est l'heure
des compliments on n'a aucune
information venant des responsables
alors autres collègues
on a décidé qu'on vient à 5 heures du
matin pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il en est
qu'est ce qu'on fait quelles sont les
mesures
quand les restos les mesures de mariée
qu'elle est responsable comment
dirais-je mettre en place et là on est
on est en train d'atteindre à ce moment
là on n'a aucun responsable jusqu'ici
qui est venu nous voir vous nous dire
quelles sont les mesures qu'est ce que
vous vendez habituellement
comment vous avez fait là pendant un
mois alors moi mais on est là pendant un
mois qu'on filière la maison puisqu'on a
eu depuis le début la thèse que je suis
à la maison et rien du tout et on est là
je là je suis je doute travailler en
iran des compliments c'est vrai que ces
unités au garde à vous la moindre des
choses je savoir pour moi les mesures
comment procéder au marquage au sol on
veut savoir ce qu'il en est et donc vous
n'avez aucune
vous n'avez aucune information aucune
information aucune information
aujourd'hui c'est notre déconfinement
alors entre marchands votre collègue on
est venu pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il en
est